عاد جنود أوزة إلى
شوارع بيونغ يانغ حيث تحتفل كوريا الشمالية
بالذكرى السنوية الثالثة والسبعين
لتأسيس البلاد مع
عرض عسكري ليلي غير عادي يتضمن
صورة غريبة لمئات من الجنود يرتدون
بدلات حمراء زاهية
وأقنعة واقية من الغازات
يتبعها باولا هانكوك.
عش من سيول ، يحب الكوريون الشماليون
عرضًا جيدًا ، لكن هذا واحد
من الكتب ، وهذا أمر غير معتاد للغاية ،
وكان مختلفًا تمامًا عما
رأيناه مؤخرًا ، إنه الثالث على
التوالي الذي رأيناه يحدث في المنتصف
في الليلة الماضية ، لكن آخرها في
يناير ، كشفوا النقاب عن مجموعة جديدة مهمة
من الأسلحة في أكتوبر من العام الماضي ، وكشفوا
عن ما
يعتقد المحللون أنه أكبر
صاروخ باليستي في العالم ، لكن هذه المرة
كان هذا بمناسبة الذكرى الثالثة والسبعين
لتأسيس صاروخ
تأسيس الدولة وكما قلت
كان هناك وحدة من هؤلاء الملثمين بالغاز
يرتدون بدلات خطيرة وكانوا
هم
وحدة الدفاع في الخطوط الأمامية أه
و  لمحاربة covid19 ، يُعتقد أن
هؤلاء
هم الأفراد الذين كانوا
يحاولون السيطرة على أه الوباء
وقد تم وصفهم على أنهم وحدة الوقاية من الأمراض الطارئة ،
لذا كان هذا العرض مختلفًا جدًا ، حيث
كانت هناك بعض
عناصر الترسانة العسكرية ، لكن كان
الأمر كثيرًا جدًا.  لا ترى في
ساحة المعركة شيئًا يتعلق
بالقدرة الصاروخية للبلد الذي
شاهدته على عربات الإطفاء ، على سبيل المثال رأيت
العمال
يتجولون في ساحة كيم إيل سونغ الآن
في منتصف الليل وفقًا
لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية التي تديرها شركة رودونغ شينمان ، فقد
رأينا كيم  جونغ أون زعيم كوريا الشمالية
يأتي ليلوح بالحشود لا
يبدو كما لو أنه أدلى بأي تعليقات في
هذه المرحلة على الأقل وفقًا
لوسائل الإعلام التي تديرها الدولة ،
لكن كان من المثير للاهتمام أنك رأيت
هذا التركيز
على السرية 19 على  الجائحة ومع
ذلك لم يكن هناك قناع يمكن رؤيته في الأفق
باستثناء تلك الوحدة التي كانت ترتدي
أقنعة واقية من الغازات ، ولم يظهر أن هناك أي
أقنعة بين آلاف الأشخاص الذين كانوا
بارعين.  هين ، ساحة كيم إيل سونغ نفسها
الآن في كوريا
الشمالية قالت إنه ليس لديها أي
حالة سرية لـ 19 حالة داخل البلد
يعتقد الخبراء أن هذا
غير مرجح تمامًا ولكن يبدو أنه
لم يكن هناك علنًا أي تفشٍ واسع النطاق
يمكننا القيام به  أه نستنتج من
الكمية المحدودة التي يمكننا رؤيتها من
وسائل الإعلام التي تديرها الدولة ولكن كما تقول جون
كان استعراضًا مختلفًا تمامًا عما
اعتدنا رؤيته من كوريا الشمالية